good morning Hank it's Tuesday my new
book turtles all the way down comes out
in exactly one week in a related story
the sound my anxiety makes is but today
I want to talk about other books I read
this year and want to recommend to you
let's do this by genre okay we'll start
with why fiction since that's what I
write aside from the hate you give which
as I said in my blurb I truly believe
will be remembered as a classic of our
time there are a few books I want to
recommend all of which made me cry
although to be fair I am a bit teary of
late first the inexplicable logic of my
life by Benjamin Alire a signs whose
books are always so tender and generous
to the reader as you'll know if you've
read Aristotle and Dante discover the
secrets of the universe but this one
might be my favorite secondly we are
okay by Nina Lacour a poetic meditation
on loss that took me right back to those
last days of adolescence with lines like
we were nostalgic for a time that wasn't
over yet
and then there's piecing me together by
Renee Watson a book that genuinely
changed the way I think about the role
art plays in human life I read this book
in two days and I have been thinking
about it for six months okay moving on
to regular grown-up literary fiction my
favorite 2017 book in that genre has to
be little fires everywhere by Celestia
which is just brilliant I mean I know
lots of people are talking about it but
with good reason it's amazing I really
think we should be talking about Celeste
Aang's books in the context of other
great chroniclers of American suburban
fiction like John Updike secondly the
king is always above the people by
Daniel alcone so full disclosure I went
to high school with Daniel where he beat
me out for the creative writing award
three years in a row and it must be said
with good reason his story still
astonished me with their precision and
their power it is no wonder that this
book is a finalist for the National Book
Award okay poetry I don't know why but
I've read a lot of poetry this year and
it's been a tremendous consolation to me
instead of like summarizing these books
I think I'm just gonna quote from them
first Nicole Seeley's ordinary beasts
you look just like your mother he says
who looks just like a fire of suspicious
origin then there's caveat cars
brilliant calling a wolf a wolf time
will break what doesn't bend even time
even you and lastly Clint Smith's
counting dissent I have always used
words to try to convince the world that
I am worth something some nonfiction I
enjoyed this year first City of Light
city of poison a history book that reads
like a thriller about the first police
chief of Paris investigating a series of
poisonings that may have involved
aristocrats close to louis xiv it is
bonkers and I especially enjoyed the
portrayals of what life was like for
regular people in 17th century Paris I
also loved city of thorns by Ben Rollins
which follows a handful of refugees over
the course of many years living in
Dadaab refugee camp which once was home
to over 500,000 to people it's a
difficult book that doesn't offer easy
answers but it shows us that refugee
stories are human stories speaking of
important topics the water will come a
book about climate change and the future
of humanity
Haggar like science books but I don't
usually find them like page Turney this
one really is it's a thriller in which
the hero in peril is us I also loved the
man who couldn't stop by David Adams
some readers of Turtles all the way down
may want to learn more about
obsessive-compulsive disorder and this
is a good place to start I also want to
say I'm looking forward to a few books
that come out this month that I haven't
read yet including nnedi okorafor Sakata
Warrior II la carte so genuine fraud and
Maggie Steve honors all the crooked
saints so my tour reading is sorted I
think but I am interested in finding out
what you're reading and enjoying in the
comments section below Hank in one week
Turtles all the way down will be out in
the world and we will be on tour
nerdfighters you can find out more about
both those things that Turtles all the
way down book comm link in the
doobly-doo below I really really hope
you enjoy the book thank you for reading
and dftba Hank I will see you on Friday